في بدايه الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
وتعليقا على سؤالا حول مزاعم استخدام
روسيا للذخائر العنقوديه قالت المتحدثه
باسم البيت الابيض وقتها جينزاكي ستكون
جريمه حرب اذا كانت صحيحه والعام الماضي
سفيره بايدن لدى الامم المتحده ليندا
توماس اكدت مثل هذه الاسلحه لا مكان لها
في ساحه المعركه جمله شطبتها الخارجيه
الامريكيه من نص كلمه جرينفيلد لكنها
اضافت اخرى
اتفاقياته جناب تحضر استخدام الذخائر
العنقوديه ضد المدنيين فقط
لا املك معلومات مؤكده لقد راينا التقارير
اذا كان الامر صحيحا فهو قد يرقى لمستوى
جريمه حرب بطبيعه الحال هناك جهات دوليه
متخصصه ستقيم الامر
والان يبدو ان روسيا تستعد لزياده وحشيه
حملتها ضد اوكرانيا لقد راينا مقاطع فيديو
للقوات الروسيه وهي تتحرك باسلحه فتاكه
الى اوكرانيا اسلحه لا مكان لها في ساحه
المعركه ويشمل ذلك الذخائر العنقوديه
والقنابل الفراغيه المحظوره بموجب اتفاقيه
جنيف
لكن بعد مرور اكثر من 500 يوم على الحرب
تغيرت القناعات اداره بايضا قررت اخيرا
وبعد سته اشهر من المناقشات ارسال الذخائر
العنقوديه الى اوكرانيا امرا كانت ترفضه
بشده في وقت سابق لكن هذه ليست المره
الاولى في تغيير القناعات تغيرت خمس مرات
منذ بدايه الحرب
هل ستوفر الولايات المتحده مقاتلات اف 16
لاوكرانيا
القنابل العنقوديه لماذا الان
نفذت الذخيره
[موسيقى]
لكن كيف تعمل الذخائر العنقوديه وكيف
يمكنها مساعده اوكرانيا في ارض المعركه في
الهجوم المضاد اولا يجب معرفه ان القنبله
الواحده يتفرع منها تقريبا 700 قنبله
متفجره صغيره تنتشر على مساحه واسعه في
ساحه المعركه وهذه الذخائر هي اسلحه تطلق
من وحده المدفعيه او من طائره اوكرانيا
تقول انها ستغير مجرى الحرب لتوضيح السبب
ولتقريب الصوره كل قنبله عنقوديه تغطي
مساحه هائله في ارض المعركه تساوي مساحه
ملعب كره قدم امريكيه كامل اي 4200 متر
مربع بتطبيق الامر على الميدان اوكرانيا
تزيد الذخائر العنقوديه لانها فعاله
للغايه ضد الاهداف الروسيه في المنطقه مثل
المشاه والمدفعيه وقوافل المركبات وللحصول
على تاثير مشابه لهذه الدخائر كان الجيش
الاوكراني يضطر لاطلاق عده مقذوفات لرؤوس
حربيه احاديه الامر كان يقلل من المخزونات
مثل الذخائر عيار 155 ملم كما يعرض
بطاريات الاطلاق للنيران المضاده الروسيه
لفتره اطول القنابل العنقوديه تمثل ايضا
درعا الدفاعيا متقدما يستهلك ذخيره الروس
الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه ستستهلك الكثير
من الصواريخ للتعامل مع القنبله العنقوديه
في العموم الذخائر نتائجها كارثيه على
المدنيين الولايات المتحده بنفسها
استخدمتها مسبقا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات